[Музика]
Привіт усім, мене звуть Ана, і
ласкаво просимо на урок англійської мови,
тому сьогодні в 9 класі ми продовжимо
працювати над темою способу життя молоді,
сьогодні ми поговоримо про
хобі, але перш ніж перейти до теми,
давайте повторимо  словниковий запас з
попереднього уроку
о, просто собаки SuperDuper я вражаю
на той момент я переміщу додаткову культуру
Парма про дружок, який працює на білому
асаді я кооператив Alexa Айдахо irako
подивіться на дошку добре
, що тут у нас є  серце, що
складається зі слів, це
слова, які ми використовуємо, щоб говорити про
різні стилі життя, тому наше завдання зараз полягає в тому,
щоб визначити, які є слова, тому
давайте почнемо з самого початку,
тому перше слово, яке ми бачимо тут,
це слово марнотратство  тож давайте запишемо
це на дошці марнотратник
це слово, яке ми використовуємо, щоб говорити про
людину, яка витрачає забагато грошей на
одяг,
добре, яке друге слово ми
бачимо на дошці мм-хм, давайте подумаємо, що це
спортивний фанат
ах  фанат спорту, тож це людина, яка
любить спорт, ці люди зазвичай купують
багато одягу та багато речей,
пов’язаних зі спортом, їхні улюблені
команди, наприклад, ок, був наступний
AHA, який працював трудоголіком, тому
трудоголік людина, яка дуже важко працює
наступне воно починається з C, а потім
ми бачимо слово диван о,
має бути ще одне ах-гу, і
є слово картопля, тож це фраза,
яку ми використовуємо, щоб говорити про людину, яка
не любить виходити на вулицю  і вони дуже
ліниві, тож була фраза, що правильно
диван картопля, давайте запишемо це так,
кушетка, чому це слово для
опису ледаря, наступне
це слово важко, так, це слово
додому, а потім у нас є слово тіло так
разом це домашнє тіло,
тому це людина, яка воліє залишитися
вдома, вона не хоче кудись виходити,
тому їм більше подобається спокій, залишайтеся
вдома,
тому наступна розмова і знову
є суфікс цього слова
наприкінці слова це говорити holic uh-huh
так само люди, які люблять розмовляти
по телефону, вони не можуть жити без своїх
телефонів, тому вони завжди розмовляють по телефону в
соціальних мережах, сканують стрічку новин і
так далі
добре, наступний це книжковий черв'як, це
правильно, так що це та людина  хто
залежний від читання, це людина,
яка не може жити без читання книг,
то наступне давайте подивимося, і
це насправді загальне слово, яке
описує наш спосіб життя, тому ми
говоримо про різні способи життя, тому
стиль життя це стиль
життя людини, як вони зазвичай відпочивають,
чим займаються на дозвіллі чи у вільний
час і так далі, добре, тепер, коли
ви згадали словниковий запас з нашого
попереднього уроку, давайте почнемо новий.
хобі, і ми
використовуємо його, щоб описати різні
види діяльності, якими ми займаємося у вільний час,
тож насправді це так, але чи знаєте ви
походження слова хобі,
ми поговоримо про нього трохи
пізніше, тепер давайте  подивіться на
визначення, яке дає Кембриджський
словник слову хобі vitae
paadam ви повинні знати, хто така машина, це
може прийти рік ризикований словник вибух
люблю хобі хобі - це діяльність, якою
хтось займається для задоволення, коли
не працює  тож коли у нас є вільний час,
коли ми не вчимося, коли ми не
працюємо, що ми робимо, ми зазвичай
займаємося хобі, і ми робимо те, що нам подобається
робити, так що це те, які хобі ви
знаєте, дайте йому щось і напишіть  список
принаймні з п'яти хобі, які ви знаєте,
можливо, ви займаєтеся цими хобі, можливо
, це те, що вам подобається робити, тому
приділіть 30 секунд, щоб написати список з п'яти
хобі,
тепер, коли ви склали список
хобі, подивіться на нього, ймовірно  у вас
є такі хобі, як читати,
слухати музику чи, можливо, щось інше, тож тепер
давайте подивимося на фотографії
з людьми та вгадайте, які їхні хобі
, тож давайте подивимося, які, на вашу
думку, хобі цих людей у
тут є  Троє людей займаються різними
видами діяльності або, можливо, вони цим не займаються
, ми просто можемо здогадатися з їх
зовнішнього вигляду, давайте подивимося на
першу картинку, тож кого ми бачимо тут, ми
бачимо дівчину, яка тримає пензлик у
руці і на неї нанесена фарба  її
щоки, а також на пальцях, тому ми можемо
припустити, що її хобі — малювання, тому вона
може бути художницею.
бачу хлопчика, який
тримає гітару, тож, ймовірно, його хобі
– гра на гітарі, добре, добре,
давайте перейдемо до наступної частини. Тут ми
побачимо чотири назви захоплень, які можуть бути
не зовсім звичайними, і те, про що ви,
можливо, не знаєте, тому ми маємо
кілька зображень, і є іграшка
коня, а потім ми можемо побачити картину, а
потім ми бачимо джойстик, пульт дистанційного
керування, так, і ми можемо побачити паперового
птаха, тож як насправді назви
ці хобі, тут у нас є онлайн-ігри
чи  igami hobby horse and gravity okay
перша перша картинка,
безперечно, кінь-хобі, це іграшка
з головою коня та палицею, тому
деяким дітям дуже подобається грати з
нею, наступна
, безперечно, малюнки графіті
на стінах наступна  той, який, звісно, означає он
айн-ігри, то
ви будете використовувати контролер для он
айн-ігор, а останній, паперовий пт
х, безумовно, означає орігамі ор
гамі, це японське мистецтво ст
орення об’єктів з паперу, тож тепер давайте по
ивимося на текст, який  насправді
розповість нам про походження слова
хобі, що таке хобі в 16
столітті улюбленою іграшкою дітей
різного віку був кінь-хобі на
вигляд кінь-хобі міг бути
простим, як палиця, або він міг бути
прикрашений дерев'яним  імітація голови коня,
чи то прості, чи
витончені діти використовували їх для
ігор того часу, пов’язаних із війною та
лицарством.
Якщо
робити щось поза рутинною
діяльністю повсякденного життя,
то слово
хобі, яке є скороченою формою хобі,
хобі коней, сьогодні включає широкий спектр
видів діяльності, визначення, яке найкраще
охоплює всі ці види діяльності, - це, ймовірно,
конструктивне дозвілля  заняття
хобі відрізняються, як смаки, якщо ви
вибрали хобі відповідно до свого
характеру та смаку,
вам пощастило, тому що ваше життя стає
цікавішим хобі розділені
на чотири великі класи
робити речі збирання речей і
навчання найпопулярнішим з усіх
груп хобі  займатися справами, що включає
в себе різноманітні види діяльності:
від садівництва до подорожей і від
шахів до онлайн-ігор. Садівництво є одним
із найдавніших хобі. Добре відомий
факт, що англійці дуже люблять
садівництво та вирощування квітів, особливо
троянд, мільйони людей.  по всьому
світу проводять відпустку, подорожуючи,
вони подорожують, щоб насолоджуватися фотографією  місцях
або просто для зміни обстановки
завжди цікаво відкривати
нові речі різні способи життя
означати різних людей їздити по-різному
їсти, слухати різні музичні
ритми макін речі включають малювання
малювання графіті макін скульптури
орігамі проектування костюмів ремесла
два з найбільш  відомими художниками-хобі
були президент Ейзенхауер і сер
Вінстон Черчілль майже кожен
щось колекціонує в певний період свого
життя марки монети сірникові коробки книги
записи листівки іграшки годинник одні
колекції не мають реальної цінності інші
стають настільки великими і цінними, що
зберігаються в музеях і галереях багато
Всесвітньо відомі колекції починалися з
одного чи двох предметів, незалежно від того, яке у
вас хобі, завжди
можливість вчитися на цьому
вчитися може бути найцікавішим
аспектом хобі. Тепер, коли ви
прочитали текст, тепер ви знаєте, що насправді
є  Походження слова hobby тому воно
походить від hobby horse at  olet
діти грали з okay, тепер наше
завдання полягає в тому, щоб поставити дієслова у
правильні форми, ви могли помітити ці
речення, згадані в тексті, тож давайте
подивимося та пригадаємо, які
саме форми слів у дужках
номер один діти використовували  адже
ігри того часу передбачають війну та
лицарство, добре,
тому нам потрібно поставити слово залучити
у правильну форму, тож, що це буде,
звичайно, це слово, яке включатиме
тут, ми маємо його як
завершення речення номер два,
але  задоволення робити щось
поза рутинною діяльністю повсякденного життя
принесло в мову нове слово,
тому задоволення від того, що не можна забувати
після слів, наприклад off after before і
так далі, ми повинні використовувати ing,
тому тут ми будемо використовувати  слово do із
закінченням ing this is it doing something
третє речення це добре відомий факт,
що англійці дуже люблять
садівництво та вирощують квіти, особливо
троянди, тому тут ми використовуємо слова як
предмети th  Те саме з садівництвом і
вирощуванням, тому не забудьте ввести
слово grow so садівництво та вирощування
квітів, і вони також вживаються після
слова off, яке є прийменником, і
четвертого речення, незалежно від того, яке у
вас хобі, воно завжди
можливість вчитися на цьому добре,
тут ми бачимо те саме правило, що й у
попередньому реченні, ту саму структуру, тож
давайте ще раз дотримуємося цього, слово
learn означає ing, і тут це добре,
добре зроблено, так що ви пам'ятаєте, як ці
форми холодні  так, правильно, вони
називаються герундієм, тому ми використовуємо форму ing
дієслова, і воно стає іменником, тож
давайте знайдемо ще кілька прикладів герундію
в тексті, подивіться ось наш текст,
і ви можете побачити їх жирним шрифтом.  Re
приклади герундію, тож перший приклад
тут у середині першого
абзацу діти використовували їх для
ігор того часу, пов’язаних із війною та
лицарством, так само, як ми щойно мали в
попередньому реченні, але задоволення від того,
щоб робити щось поза межами  th  їхня рутинна
діяльність однакова. Це герундій,
де ще ми можемо знайти його.
Хобі передостаннього абзацу розділені на
чотири великі класи робити
речі, колекціонувати речі та вивчати
речі, це також геррани, а
в останньому абзаці тут перший
речення найпопулярніше
з усіх груп хобі - робити речі добре,
де ще ми можемо побачити герундій тут
прямо в першому реченні першого
абзацу в новій частині тексту
Ім'я Бога - одне з найстаріших захоплень
Англійці дуже люблять садівництво  і
вирощування квітів у наступному реченні
мільйони людей по всьому світу
проводять відпустку, подорожуючи,
де ще можна отримати герундій
чи третій абзац тут робить речі
включають малювання живопис виготовлення
скульптур створення костюмів слова
, виділені жирним шрифтом, герундій добре і
останнє, давайте поглянемо на
останній абзац, незалежно від того, яке у
вас хобі, це завжди
можливість Лі  Навчання з нього
може бути найцікавішим аспектом,
тому слова, виділені жирним шрифтом, є прикладами
герундію, використаного в тексті, а тепер давайте
подивимося на правила, що описують
використання герундію білі епендимоми,
ймовірно, не перейшли через cordova moko дотримуйтесь
IMO  ing zack геніально,
тому існує багато виразів go plus gerund або дієслово
plus ing, що використовуються для пригодницьких
видів спорту та індивідуальних розважальних
заходів, наприклад, я ходжу плавати
кожні вихідні, тож ми маємо go плюс
gerund або go плюс дієслово з ing go
плаваю та наступний приклад  Ви
б ще раз стрибали з парашутом,
це пригода,
це вид спорту, тому go skydiving
нам потрібно використати ing в кінці
дієслова skydive ok і є ще одне, за
деякими дієсловами зазвичай слідує
герундій, який є третім плюсом  ing, як ви
вже знаєте, але за ними також може бути
іменник плюс інфінітив
, тобто два плюс дієслово, тож давайте
подивимося на приклади, перший із яких я
порадив сісти на
потяг  загалом, це означає, що я радив
взагалі не комусь особисто,
тому загалом добре їхати потягом
тут, тому я раджу сісти потягом,
це спосіб, яким ми повинні використовувати це тут,
але давайте подивимося на другий
приклад і порівняємо  тут ми говоримо, що я
порадив йому сісти на поїзд, тож це
означає, що він сіде потягом, і
ми порадили це комусь особисто,
тому це не загальна, а
персоналізована порада, добре, тому
це два основних правила щодо герундію та до
плюс інфінітив  контрастуйте зараз, давайте
потренуйтеся, щоб тут ви могли побачити
речення, у яких потрібно виконати завдання
з кількома виборами. Наше завдання
— вибрати правильні слова, щоб заповнити
прогалини
oh jezereth Громадяни бомбардувальники Деніела за
кордоном провінція лава Маленький магазин
підпорядкований зонди можуть взяти  подивіться
на номер один
Каріанн вивчає серфінг, працюючи
щодня, про що ми говоримо тут,
ми насправді говоримо про фізичну
активність, тож із словом go ми використаємо
щось  це означає хобі, яке
є свого роду спортом, тож чи є якісь
типи підтримки, це серфінг, тож ми скажемо, що
Керрі Енн займається серфінгом щодня, а
Делорес ходить, коли у неї є
час на походи в гори, на
заняття в тренажерному залі  бачиш у гостях у її
матері, то що вона робить, вона
робить щось правильно,
але що саме вона робить, тому ми,
ймовірно, теж
знову говоримо про фізичну активність,
яка є фізична активність,
відвідує її маму,
певно, не займається в спортзалі, але ви
зазвичай виконуємо вправи, тому єдине,
що нам потрібно використовувати тут, це похід
у гори
номер три Сем поїхав зупинитися в
готелі, оглянути визначні пам'ятки, побачити, побачити музеї
в Парижі, тож що він насправді зробив
, не забувайте, що там дуже гарний  фразу
англійською, коли ви подорожуєте і коли ви
їдете подивитися якісь цікаві місця в
новому місті, ви зазвичай ходите на огляд визначних пам'яток, тому
насправді це варіант, який нам
потрібно вибрати тут, тому ми скажемо, що
Сем побачив  бачити в Парижі хорошу
кількість наразі Ліз і Курт збираються йти
сьогодні ввечері
куди вони збираються йти сьогодні ввечері їли
їсти вечерю дивитися фільм дивитися
танці який з них фізична активність
тут їсти вечерю не дуже це
дивитися фільм насправді це більше
про розслаблення та танці, це
фізична активність, так, звісно, тому ми ск
жемо, що сьогодні ввечері вони підуть на танці на
тупний номер п’ятий Джеймі ні
оли не ходив тусуватися купувати чи ро
ити покупки в цьому торговому центрі, що це за кріт, як
й зазвичай  торговий центр, тож ми
говоримо про покупки, і це
варіант C, який нам потрібно використовувати тут, ми
скажемо, що Джеймі ніколи не ходив за покупками
в цьому торговому центрі, добре, і останнє речення
в цій вправі давайте подивимося на
номер шість, коли Патрік хотів піти  теннісон
їжа боулінг боулінг зі своїми друзями,
але йому довелося працювати допізна,
тож, по-перше, що для вас звучить більш
природно
грайте у футбол, але ви ходите в боулінг, так
що ось тут, давайте перейдемо до наступної
частини завдання, а тепер нам потрібно
вибрати правильну відповідь зі слів,
виділених курсивом іменна дитина не за кордоном.
скоропис на давайте подивимося
на перше речення
Деббі закликала відвідати
Ейфелеву вежу або їх відвідати Ейфелеву вежу, коли вони були в
Парижі,
тому закликала їх відвідати Ейфелеву вежу чи закликала їх
відвідати Ейфелеву вежу, ми говоримо про
індивідуальне бажання чи говоримо
про щось загальне  імовірно,
Деббі розмовляла з кимось особисто тут,
нам доведеться вибрати їх для відвідування, тому
Деббі закликала їх відвідати Ейфелеву
вежу, поки вони були в Парижі, тому
вона не розмовляла взагалі, вона
говорила з людьми особисто вдруге, як
я пам'ятаю, як я потрапив до  вставати о 4:30
ранку, щоб встигнути на роботу вчасно, щоб я
пам’ятав, як вставав або вставав, якщо ми
говоримо про минулі дії, ми повинні
використовувати слово отримати я пам’ятав, що
встав о 4:30 ранку  . щоб встигнути
працювати вчасно, так, Аміата
Укія, яка виступає за Каддафі, оша 23 сказала, що Ронко має
принести їй нового робота на вибір,
тепер третій, якого вчитель математики не
дозволяє нам використовувати або використовувати калькулятори, тому
вчитель не дозволяє в  загальні
чи деякі конкретні люди, так, ми
говоримо про конкретних людей, тут
ми маємо слово «нас», тому, якщо ми говоримо
про когось особисто, нам
потрібно використовувати інфінітив, тому ми скажемо,
що вчитель математики не знає  дозвольте
нам скористатися калькуляторами номер чотири Саллі
хотіла залишитися або ми залишитися довше, але
я був настільки втомлений, що нам довелося піти,
це взагалі персоналізоване, Саллі
хотіла просто, щоб хтось залишився чи
вона хотіла, щоб хтось особистий хтось
точний  залишайся довше правильно, вона хотіла, щоб ми
залишилися довше, але я був так втомлений, і нам
довелося жити, тому наступного номеру
п'ять японська вчителька заохочувала говорити
або заохочувала учнів говорити в
класі знову, у нас є люди,
якими був учитель японської мови  розмовляючи з тут,
нам потрібно використовувати інфінітив, тому ми
скажемо, що вчитель японської мови
заохочував учнів говорити на уроці добре,
шостий, який консультант порадив
зменшити або їм зменшити витрати, ми можемо
припустити, що консультант працював з
кимось, так що  чому ми скажемо,
що консультант порадив їм зменшити
витрати номер сім,
мені потрібна допомога або ви, допоможіть мені
ще раз перемістити стіл, ось ми
звертаємося до когось, і нам потрібна допомога
від когось точно, так від людини,
коли у нас є індивідуальний запит  ми
будемо використовувати інфінітив Мені потрібно, щоб ти
допоміг мені перемістити стіл номер вісім,
доглядач зоопарку дозволив торкатися або нам
торкнутися змії чи зазвичай керуючий зоопарку
дозволяє торкатися змії
всім, ні нам, тому тут нам потрібно
ще раз використати інфінітив  він дозволив
нам доторкнутися до змії наступної
цифри дев'ять, ви не проти почекати або я
почекаю ще кілька хвилин,
це не лише індивідуальне запитання,
але й слово розум, яке потребує
тож ми маємо сказати, чи не заперечуєте ви почекати ще
кілька хвилин, і під номером 10
курс піших походів вимагає кемпінг або ми розташовуємось
у снігу, що ви думаєте,
звичайно, це вимагає, щоб ми таборували в
снігу добре, так що тепер ви знаєте, що
різниця між використанням герундію та to plus
інфінітиву в англійській мові,
і тепер настав час для домашнього завдання, давайте
поглянемо на дошку, ваше домашнє завдання
полягає в тому, щоб написати три речення з go плюс
герундій, який є go плюс дієслово з
виразами ing, які використовуються, наприклад, для спорту
Я бігаю щодня.
Друга частина вашого домашнього завдання
— написати чотири речення з фразами «
хотіти щось зробити, потрібно щось зробити,
порадьте комусь щось зробити
або дозвольте комусь щось зробити,
так сім речень, які
маєте написати ви, добре,
це  це на сьогодні дуже дякую
за увагу, побачимося наступного разу
[Музика].